it's the oldest question on earth
where did we come from
some people may think a creator from
above but
what if the hand that created humanity
wasn't divine
what if
aliens brought life to earth
how could a meteor carry life to our
planet
could microbes survive the cold vacuum
of space
and
does alien life
already exist on earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if aliens brought life to earth
when you think of aliens your
imagination might run wild with movie
scenes and x-files reruns but
technically an alien includes anything
not from earth
and that broad definition opens up some
intriguing possibilities
in 2017 astronomers detected a
mysterious chunk from an exoplanet that
entered our solar system
called omuamua this interstellar object
is made from nitrogen ice
the perfect radiation shield for an
organism that might be hitching a ride
after all if this pancake shaped rock
can keep its ice formation while flying
through the galaxy
then
maybe life can not only exist beyond the
solar system
but
also travel frozen in space
but if an object like this slammed into
earth
would the organisms survive the impact
when our solar system was still forming
the chunk of rock that would become
earth floated around completely
unprotected from meteors and asteroids
if an object like omuamua had landed on
earth during that time
it could have brought microbes and other
organisms from deep space
this is called the panspermia theory
which states that matter from
surrounding planets or objects from deep
space
might have brought life to earth
but how could we test this theory
researchers aboard the international
space station found that bacteria
survived on the panels outside the
station
even the extreme temperatures of space
didn't kill the bacteria
oh what does that prove well if a
spacecraft left from mars with microbial
life attached
those microbes could survive the trip to
earth
but let's go back to the early days of
our planet almost 4 billion years ago
earth went through a bombardment period
during this time powerful meteor showers
regularly rocked the surface of our
world and several objects the size of
omuamua about 800 meters long crashed
into the earth
so if there were microbes deep within
those meteors they might have been
cushioned from the impact
and that's pretty impressive considering
meteors travel at speeds of up to 100
kilometers per second
and during that chaotic time
life began springing up all over earth
after all bacteria can thrive in
temperatures as high as 113 degrees or
be preserved at minus 196 degrees
so
if those meteors had contained microbial
life it would have survived the impact
and possibly planted the seeds of life
but
how could we know if alien life is
already here
well that evidence is harder to find we
still haven't found life anywhere other
than earth so
thinking that life could have come from
somewhere else might be a bit of a
stretch
but in a system 400 light years away
we have found the elements of life
using radio telescope technology danish
researchers found glycoaldehyde a simple
sugar needed to produce ribonucleic
acids or rna
this is the macromolecule responsible
for making proteins and coding genes
glycoaldehyde is floating out there in
space
waiting for a carrier to bring it to a
world like ours
but maybe it's already here
amino acids and sugars the building
blocks of life come in two versions that
mirror each other
we call this phenomenon chirality and we
refer to the versions as left and right
but on earth all life contains
left-handed shaped amino acids and
right-handed shaped sugars
and that's unusual as scientists
creating amino acids in a lab would make
half of them left-handed and half
right-handed so single shapes in amino
acids and sugars could be an
evolutionary function
or
they could be
an extraterrestrial influence
you know whether life came to earth from
outside our solar system in a rock or
on the bottom of an alien's foot it's
hard to ignore this theory when we think
about our place in the universe
but
what if
our planet has spread life in the same
way
what if ancient life escaped earth
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you